a yes-or-no answer
you are telling us tonight that you will
remain justly clearly yes or no Arthur
you're telling us tonight you will
remain neutral on the issue of whether
or not we should remain within the and
the way that you've spoken about race in
the past is completely characteristic of
the way your government has dealt with
all the issues it's gone up across since
2010 it's been characterized by complete
carelessness by callousness the way you
treat people through the DWP where you
treated the victims of rain fell the
hostile environment it's like it's
completely well you say you visited
hospitals and you've spoken to public
service workers but I think you yourself
know you haven't been welcomed when
you've been to speak to them the way
you've conducted yourself when you've
been there they shown that you're afraid
of the response you're going to get so I
think it's I think it's insulting to the
people who've suffered under your
government even if you say you've only
been you know in power for a hundred
days you've been part of the government
for the last nine years I think it's
completely insulting for you for you to
stand there and talk about all the
investment you're going to bring when
it's your austerity policies that have
brought
in Arkansas like all I can say to you is
to repeat my what I've said actually are
in this party in the Conservative Party
unlike other parties we have zero
tolerance of Islamophobia we do we and
people are asked to stand down if
they're guilty of Islamophobia or or any
other prejudice or any other hate speech
and and and that is what we that's what
we do and that's i think mr corbyn's
position it seems to mutated tonight
he's not he now what she's now going to
be neutral on the deal that he proposes
to do I don't see how he can do a deal
when he the deal that he wants to do
never mind that
I do not think whatever deal mr corbyn
purposes I don't think it's sensible for
this great country of ours to spend next
year in yet more delectable disputations
about the EU and and and then another
referendum if I understood correctly
won't have an early on another
referendum on Scotland how can that be
right for our country
you